dink-dink podcast sorry you scared
everyone I think camera lights an action
we are back for another podcast welcome
back thank you for joining us this
episode is brought to you by the skin
learn all of what's going on in the
world that we live in and a very easy
and convenient to consume fashion this
game is a newsletter that comes in your
email with all the top stories that you
need to know about it's completely free
go to the skim th es ki mm - MS com
slash annejulien sign your email and
click subscribe that's it you also enter
to win into a $50 Visa gift card also
calm it is an amazing app that one of
our newer sponsors and it is helpful for
mindfulness meditation calming yourself
distressing yourself helping yourself
sleep a lot of amazing things I've tried
it it is truly an awesome thing go to
see ALM calm slash Jenna Julianne
check it out you get 25% off comm
premium subscription with that link and
also honey book guys if you're running a
small business and you don't know how to
deal with all the business size of
things if you're an artistic person or
even just smart in another way and you
just don't get the way business works
honey book is there to help you they
have all the tools to make business easy
and successful for you right now go to
honey book H ome ybo ok.com
use promo code generally for 50% off
your first year more on that later
Thank You sponsors well be gentle with
my BOB well there where are we today oh
I think you already know Doolin hi I'm
Robert Herjavec welcome to shark tank no
that's not the voice of shark tank he's
like the fourth person I want to hear hi
I'm Mark Cuban I'm I don't eat gluten
except for sometimes except for if I
feel like it and shut up I'm rich oh hi
I'm mr. wonderful everyone makes fun of
my bald head I laugh about it but
honestly that's kind of [ __ ] mean why
do people do that also
winde play the song
hi i'm barbara corcoran I'm delightful
and very smart hi I'm Lorie Grenier I'm
[ __ ] dope as hell I'm looking here
and I'm the business [ __ ] really that's
what it was an office joke but she's the
business [ __ ] hm [ __ ] is a good term
hi I'm Bethenny Frankel I don't know why
I'm on this show but I'm on here several
times he fit tea that was enough it tea
sorry that was that was uncalled for
I'm very sorry okay you ready welcome to
the shark tank okay okay okay
and we're instantly good instant claim
shark a shark a shark - sorry sir - Inc
okay in the shark tank okay well first
of all we don't hold on you're not
welcoming anyone you're the contestant
first of all we did one of these
podcasts and it's really funny because
Julian is always trying to come up it's
like snake oil but you come up with your
own cards and your own invention no no
stupid and Shark Tank is one of my
favorite shows it's one of your favorite
shows - it's just really entertaining
and there's a lot to learn on there - as
well it's educational and fun and
entertaining and great it's the great
show anyways if you don't live in a
country where you can watch Shark Tank
it's basically people have businesses or
small things that they'd like investors
to invest in so they go into the shark
tank and they pitch their ideas and/or
existing businesses to people with lots
of money they can invest in and grow
their businesses so Julian has compiled
some businesses or inventions that I met
were compiled from the old gold mine up
here mm-hmm and he's going to pitch them
to me this is the second time we've done
this podcast the first one included some
inventions such as vitamin ketchup smell
cloud my
I mean my fitness is if we had Mouse
blood among others all doing very well
by the way I'll have you know oh yeah
making me lots of passive money also
passive lawsuits but money too
so first up in the tank we have what's
your name Julian Julian here he comes
you don't have to spend your gonna
unplug your headset marble also doesn't
have to spend Thank You jerks
Thank You sharks welcome it's just me
Thank You shark you very impressive
amounts of teeth in your mouth
thank you I can't stop swimming girls
all died is that true of sharks mm-hmm
you know wait sharks what
babies are a lot of work don't you know
do you have a baby if you don't it's
okay I can tell you right now that there
are a lot of work I've heard about it do
you have a B I don't have a baby oh if I
did I wouldn't have time there have made
this okay babies are a lot of work if
you have one you know and if you don't
have one you probably know someone who's
told you that they're a lot of work but
one of the things that's the hardest
with babies is when you want to feed
them and they don't want you to feed
them so I hear I don't have a baby I
don't have any reason to have made this
invention but I made it
sometimes your baby is just like your
baby be like no no I don't want to eat
but you be like they need to eat they
need to survive I need to feed them so
they slap the food away from you they
turn their head they're screaming and
they're so it's not an infant baby maybe
it's like a year old baby it works from
zero to two okay okay yeah depending on
the baby okay maybe five but sometimes
they just don't want to eat so toddler
already didn't interrupt you okay I'm
sorry okay listen sometimes they just
don't want to eat and you as an adult or
like they need to eat they need to
survive they need sustenance
and sometimes use like eat it and
they're like no and so then you're like
what do I do
here's what you do you get yourself a
googoo gimble it's a gimbal that you
would normally put a camera on to
stabilize but it's for your baby the
Google gimbal is a 3-axis stabilized rig
gimbal for your wild crazy infant now
when they're gonna go in crazy their
head will be steady and smooth ready to
feed their arms and legs and body can be
flailing about but because of our three
axis technology previously used on
cameras the baby's head will remain
completely still and ready to eat we
also have attached little speakers on
the gimbal that are they play songs
supposedly studies show that the songs
help them eat too so right now struggle
no more with your baby and get the
Google gimbal double-a batteries not
included do I start the questions now
double-a batteries are not included but
it they also don't run on double-a
batteries that's why they're not
included no batteries are included what
is on his face it's like a little ball
of marbled fur I have several questions
just imagine this okay he's bad at it
where the egg is give me the I need to
do demonstrations where's Pete
oh no we've lost one I need you for a
presentation come wait Julian what so
does eat outside I didn't let her
outside she was up here last time I
checked oh no we lost we lost Pete why
she's probably on the counter somewhere
oh no she is peachy where were you look
at this ready here's the demonstration
keep steady see your head sting right
don't you wish your baby could do this
when their body's flailing about their
head stay still you could probably eat
right now
I have several girls several questions
Julian yes go ahead please so is it the
baby go
in the gimbal not the food right baby
yes and how does it keep their head
steady if their body is moving three
axis three axis okay
can you tell me what that means I'd have
to make some calls I don't know what it
means but it's three axis is there a
seat like no you strap their head in
just their head yeah you're aware that
their head this is separate like it's
still part of their body yeah you strap
their head in uh-huh and then the gimbal
is the motor and so the motor attaches
to their chest they become like a little
baby Iron Man and so then whatever their
body's doing their head is stabilized
from their body it's a 3 axis gimbal are
you sure that this isn't a form of
torture three out of our five babies who
we try to learn like that so I don't
speak baby but I think they like this so
this you're essentially if you take out
the word gimbal yeah you're putting them
in something that keeps their head
facing forward and steady yeah people
have dubbed it as chamber we don't like
that term it's Google gimbal it's it's
as its as peaceful and wonderful and
smooth looking as a camera gimbal just
with your infant baby uh-huh okay and
how does it solve the problem of them
not wanting to eat well it studies their
head so at a certain point they don't
really have a choice the food's going in
because their head study I mean it's so
smooth you should see a technology we
stole it from who I can't say I actually
can't say okay and have you invented it
yet yes we have one prototype do so you
have no sales no no no okay
is it safe like I said three out of our
five babies liked it 2 out of our 5 we
don't really talk to those babies
anymore they didn't really help us very
much it screamed a lot do you want to
know how much it's gonna cost
yeah how much does it cost $500 $500
good price for gimble it must can be way
way above that and those only hold
cameras we hold humans is it baby food
not included okay
also if you get any baby food on the
gimble it breaks it shorts the circuit
and might electrocute your baby not not
not real
but maybe why is it electric what do you
think's powering the motor why is there
a motor well there's three accesses
three axes Julian I'm just imagining
your baby okay
and now imagine your baby but a chicken
and their bodies flying all the way
around and their heads just completely
still and smooth but that doesn't
completely this spoon comes in boom but
what if they close their mouth they spit
the food out it doesn't solve any of
those problems maybe work on your
parenting there a little bit I have some
serious safety concerns okay what if we
made it not electric what if we made it
powered by quick vibes Julian inertia
kinetic energy you know like if they
move it powers it mmm have to talk to my
scientists I don't think they'll like
the fact that they don't get electricity
for this but what do you think if I can
make that happen is it adjustable or is
it just for babies like what if a baby
has a really big head we might uh no no
no if your baby is a big head we are not
the product for you I'm sorry I don't
know what to say I'm sure you have a
wonderful baby but the head size must be
standard otherwise it won't work
typically how long does it take for a
baby to grow out of your invention
there's a sweet spot of like three
months that it fits
after that the Google gimbal will no
longer support their head in fact it
might actually just cause erratic
movements and before that it might smack
them in the face because it won't be
completely on a snug so there's a sweet
spot sweet spot of three months that
throughout those three months you will
be sleeping like a baby because your
baby is so well fed I appreciate your
pitch Julian but I'm gonna have to be
out I have some how about two hundred
dollars serious safety I dropped in over
15%
you only have one it doesn't matter what
you sell it for it do you have a baby
here because I
try it there's no babies in the truck
thing no there's no babies in the shark
tank you have to bring your own baby for
the presentation okay but because you
didn't and because it sounds like a
chamber of torture I'm out they'd be
getting food but I don't know
hey listen okay you want to talk to the
babies they tried it they liked it only
three out of five liked it
yeah I'm gonna talk to those bang on
baton 600 okay have you ever watched
baseball that's a good batting average
okay okay well no more Google gimble I
guess next
are you in yet Thank You sharks poop
Julian did that offend you no it didn't
offend me it was just loud and gross I
think it offended you do you want to be
near me after I said that poop different
different opinions than yours okay poop
all of those things made you don't want
to be near me right no I just don't want
to okay but provided we're actually
undertaking you don't know me yeah but
it's it's not the subject matter it's
the fact that you just came in here and
shouted something at me well I want to
get your attention number two it's the
type of attention that you want to stay
very far away from do you hate your
neighbors Julian wait what because a lot
of people hate their neighbors and with
good reason that the studies show that
over 35% of neighbors are dicks and the
people living next to them are
constantly subjected to their dickish
behavior and they have no choice because
that's the house they be they live in
well worry no more because we have you
covered how are we gonna have you
covered literally with a fence not the
white picket fence you see in the movies
no this one is gonna be riddled with
offensive language introducing offensive
is a fence with offensive things written
all over the front of it so no one will
ever come near your house okay ever
again if your neighbors are bothering
you
if the UPS guy wants to throw your
package and break it no more
they're gonna read your fence once and
they're gonna want nothing to do with
that also if they attack your house I
throw rocks for your windows you can't
sue us it's part of the small print
there's a hundred percent guarantee your
neighbors will be offended there's not a
half that guarantee they won't do
anything in retaliation but they will be
offended so if you need to get back at
your neighbors and offend them and keep
them away by offensive okay how was it
how was it written on there is it like
spray paint
something I could do myself or is this
something no no no no so if I were to
just go outside and graffiti my own wall
with something offensive what I also
have made offensive while you would have
infringed on our patent bar utility
patent okay so all graffiti is
infringing on your utility patent yeah
okay I bought my utility patent off eBay
but I think it's pretty good okay but
yeah you can't do graffiti on the fence
we have a patented printer that have you
ever seen a real printer mm-hmm
instead of putting paper in the back we
put fences in the magnet it just slides
through and then it comes out with
offensive language okay can you give me
an idea of the type of offensive ID I
can it's actually because we were live
on the internet and I don't want to be
held liable for those we're live on the
Internet
oh okay this is shark tank this is a
shark tank like icarly but shark tank
we're live I don't want to get in
trouble for saying anything offensive
but just think of the most offensive
thing that you could imagine and that
that's where we'll be on the fence
okay so if I buy offensive yep and I put
it up yeah don't you think it would
violate several it would violate our
like community like they would write a
petition or write to the city or
something that they don't want that in
their community anymore okay noted so
there's this new attachment we're gonna
sell on top of the fences it's a gloss
coating okay
it looks like nothing in the daytime but
if you were to take a photo of it the
flash allows the coating to turn into
like a reflective surface so no pictures
of it can be taken so therefore there
will be no evidence of your offensive
and people cannot report you okay to the
authorities
I like the idea because I do know that
it exists that people really really hate
their neighbors I'm not one of those
people this isn't a problem that I need
to solve nor am i I personally am very
very good friends with all of my
neighbors they oftentimes bring me fresh
fruit and vegetables from their garden
they are just the most wonderful I could
not imagine having anything less than
that as a neighbor so if you have a
shitty neighbor that really sucks I
can't relate at all but buy my product I
do think that there is
definitely a market for your product and
that some people would really enjoy it
mm-hmm how much is it will we charge per
square inch
where is yes square square inch it's two
cents an inch in two cents that's so
cheap you have two cents laying around
that's a whole inch of yard space you
just covered with offensive language
okay that's it's a good price terrible
thing yeah you know it's not for me but
I do think that it is for someone and
that they could have it up and have a
really good time before it got taken
down you know okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and invest what type of investment I
would love to I would love for you to
invest in 10% of the company mm-hmm the
payment not required all I need you to
do is show up in court if we ever get
taken to court I can't be the one I've
been hired to strike so you don't have
to pay me just you have 10% if you're
willing to take the hit you know I
believe in people's freedom of
expression and it hurts me sometimes you
know when someone just wants to like
plant a tree somewhere or like build a
fence or something and their commute or
paint their house a certain color and
their communities like no you ruin in
the neighborhood yeah I believe that
people should be able to have offensives
if they want mm-hmm stick it to them
yeah offensive we have we have a deal oh
it's good to be a nice with you
I only communicate on whatsapp okay
that's fine okay so don't text me and
there can't be anything like deeply
racist or anything on there only cuss
words I
I'm not the one who writes it I have a
really really terrible person of a
friend okay I'm up with all of the
offensively yeah okay
only cuss words and then we have a deal
I'll talk to him see what we can do and
yes okay deal then okay I made a deal
with my second inventions you're doing
good this round
hey sharks the music isn't done hey hola
hola sharks do you hear that you hear
that jerks do you hear those barks I
think that's the sound of your dog I
think they're pretty hungry my name is
Julian and I'm here to talk about a new
invention for you and your dogs do you
ever cook pasta marinara and
accidentally spill some on the ground
whoops
splat it's a big mess on your floor
luckily if you have a dog they come lick
it right up and you say I'm so thankful
for my dog they're pretty much a Swiffer
mm-hmm and then you say oh no it had
garlic and onion in it they might get
sick and poop and then you have a stress
out moment and you freak out and
hopefully they don't get sick but you
still are also glad that they cleaned it
up because even though it's gonna make
them sick like it's not fun anymore I
mean it's kind of nice also this is
something that I face a lot cuz
literally like five days a week I make
pasta marinara it's like me the main
thing I eat you don't oh sorry
I eat pasta marinara five days a week
minimum that's a lot yeah I like it a
lot okay we're not here to talk about my
eating habits well worry no more because
now when you're in the mood to
recklessly cook some pasta marinara five
out of seven nights a week and the Navy
spill some on the floor to where your
dog can clean it up it will be safe for
dogs introducing M bark and Aris ah it's
exactly the same as marinara just with
no garlic and onion patented are we
patented our recipe no one else can take
out onion and garlic of the recipe
because it's now ours now you can spill
as much bark aneri on the floor your dog
is gonna lap it right up and have so
many just nutritional improvements their
body is gonna thank them they're gonna
be satiated you also have this plastic
that we put in it that prevents it from
reaching a certain temperature so yes
you're eating plastic okay but hold bear
with me the plastic prevents it from
being too hot so you're never gonna have
your dog burn their mouth they might eat
plastic and so will you if you actually
eat this I've been eating Barkin air for
three months and aside from a few kidney
stones I've noticed no change in my body
Julianne yes what what what listen I
really think that your hearts in the
right place with this product you're
thinking about your heart burning from
all this bark and arrow sauce that's
where this I think your hearts in the
right place about thinking about your
dog but you're essentially selling
crushed Tomatoes if it not garlic or
onion my crushed tomatoes don't have
garlic and onion do you know the base of
a marinara sauce that's garlic onion and
tomatoes no it's tomato oregano but all
of that is up to you good damn right
it's up to me you're selling me worst it
comes in a tube okay it's more
convenient for storage and travel can be
all you have to do say it's fresh then
it becomes fries
I don't want my dog to eat onions and
garlic or plastic what about but the
onions and garlic we know is bad for
them we don't know for sure that plastic
is bad for clean I'm pretty sure we know
for sure send me one study where they
fed plastic to dogs okay that's a
terrible study that doesn't need to
answer this exactly no studies Julian no
fine show me a study where animals ate
nuclear waste and decided it was bad for
them my agent will email you okay thank
you so if I so feasibly if I were to
take out the plastic you would be okay
well then you just have crushed Tomatoes
well we have a secret recipe and I'd
appreciate if you didn't reveal the
ingredients live on the internet because
it might foil our whole company okay so
what is it cost because the can of
crushed Tomatoes isn't that expensive
well we prefer Bitcoin we will accept
dollars US dollars I don't have a
Bitcoin - so will we I'm not saying we I
mean if you have it well we can talk do
you know anyone who's Bitcoin Julian I I
think the price is $14.99 Bitcoin no no
dollars okay
but if you have Bitcoin we can talk
about a different situation I'm asking
for 30 percent of the company
all you have to do is give me your dog
okay
no I don't want payment I'm out I need
more dogs for testing Julian what here I
can solve your problem for you okay when
you're cooking sauce don't splash it all
around the room what about your poor dog
who's hungry
they feed your dog food for your dog I
don't understand okay I'm out so no one
barking there
no one barking there I don't want to
walk into a grocery store and look at
crushed Tomatoes marinara sauce Barkin
era
there's nothing about Barkan era that
makes me want to buy pivot we're doing a
dog restaurant it's called Barkin air
it's an Italian food restaurant for dogs
only okay I'm listening no garlic and
onion anything everything is a true
authentic Italian dish cooked by dogs
in the kitchens and our main dish is
pasta bar canary okay I'm honestly
down.we I think that it might be a
little bit difficult to serve food where
there's also animals but the dog that so
the FDA can't come in because it's dogs
only eating uh-huh
if you're a human that eats in there you
you're not protected by so you can bring
your own food as a person but all of the
food that is served there is only for
dogs
yes it's not recommended to eat there if
you're a human because it is filthy and
nothing is clean right you might get
sick okay but dogs also eat their own
[ __ ] diarrhea and cat poop and
garbage okay I'm I'm willing to listen
to a restaurant peach where you going a
restaurant for dogs tell me about your
your business that you just made up so
it's a fine fast casual Italian
authentic dining drive-through
restaurant for dogs your optional
optional how can it if your dog prefers
to go through the drive-thru they can
okay mainly a seating area hmm and what
do you do if there's like a dog fight no
no absolutely not a problem we only
serve well-behaved dog so if you're
gonna bring a fight into our
establishment you can get on you can
boogy boogy bark up on out of here I
like the concept thank you I like the
idea that it's authentic Italian even
though it has no onion or garlic which
makes it not authentic we have a
scientist currently working on a garlic
substitute okay what about an onion
substitute do I know what the garlic
substitute is called what NARR lick
should I get out and leave now no
reservations allowed how much are you
asking for me to invest can you just
post on Instagram about it once and then
you got a deal thank you I'm very
excited about working with you once and
then never again you didn't even say it
had to be positive you got a deal all
right I'll be back next year for gnarl
ik okay that's my next dog safe car
invention gnarly garlic ready good pitch
good pivot hi sharks
you are all very rich is your life too
common boring cuz I feel like it
probably is you have all the money you
want him you don't have any problems
really that's not true
I know I know it's okay all right do you
have no worry stress or anxiety ever in
your life I know that that's how some
people are do you want some introducing
the app that gives you no calm energy
and no peace chaos it is an app I
developed that provides tones music
voices and sound scapes that help you
wake the [ __ ] up and feel intense no
drugs allowed we have a library of over
10 different programs that add a jolt to
your day featuring ASM are you sure
about that
the trend john cena narrated scream
scape that will be sure to rattle you
until later tonight while many suffer
from stress and anxiety some also don't
so if you need something we got you 69
dollars in the App Store get it now
before it's taken down $69 yes it is
over 10 programs you can listen to ten
programs how long are the programs one
of which is John Cena screaming for 13
minutes oh really you're allowed to use
it yeah yeah yeah but just hurry up and
buy it because it might get taken down I
don't know how the app store works I'm
honestly like I like the idea of an app
or something like that that is not like
those calm anxiety apps it's for the
opposite it's too just like rattle you
and wake you up and make sure that
you're going thank you I don't know from
experience how much I would like to
listen to people screaming you haven't
tried to endure other chaotic noises
especially considering my partner that I
live with is very chaotic sometimes it
sounds like you're a cool guy it doesn't
always make me feel motivated it makes
me feel out of my [ __ ] mind
that's kind of the goal oh okay yeah you
I'm monied to lower that price I don't
think I want to pay $69 for an app can
you get it to like a dollar 99 cents or
free with some advertisements depending
on how much you invest because right now
I've made no money for like what are you
asking how much you offering okay that's
not how this works
how much you have are near that's not
others works I am NOT Mayweather there
is no cash on me stop pointing at my
chest those pockets No
can I see your pockets just empty your
pockets okay this is a stick-up this is
a pineapple onesies give me your money
oh you have nothing um just give me a
blank check and we'll talk about later
no do you need to lower the app to $0.99
or for $0.99 yes well I need to break
even on about a thousand purchases of
the $69 price point so 69 thousand
dollars in real we're good now can have
No Deal you can have 70% of the company
deal thank you also John Cena's people
have been calling me I don't know yes
you like to eat feeldog no we shook it
doesn't matter we shook on TV well the
opposite of that is calm and that is a
really good Wow okay and yes if you're
asking yourself did Julian just really
write an entire invention in shark tank
pitch as a segue to a sponsor well the
answer would be yes and also you're
smart person for noticing that because
calm is a sponsor of the podcast and it
is the direct opposite of what I just
sold here on Shark Tank it is a really
really great app and I've actually tried
it and I love it it helps you with any
number of different things that you
might struggle with anxiety stress sleep
if you struggle with sleep calm has got
you covered
it's the number one app for sleep can
you stop touching me please I'm doing a
sales pitch a good night's sleep is like
a magic remedy for the brain and body
and sometimes it is just it eludes you
and I know this because it happens to me
all the time calm is a really great app
if you have zero experience with
meditation or anything like that they
help you it is
guided it is explained as as you go and
also it's not a one-size-fits-all you
kind of go into the app and select what
you need help with are you stressed are
you anxious do you struggle to sleep
whatever it is and you select it and
then they build a program basically for
those needs and it is really great and
if you have headphones or air pods
because all the kids be rocking those
these days just pop those in when you're
getting some stuff done around and
throughout the day and listen to some
comet will really help give you some
mindfulness and today it is very hard to
find that with all of the distractions
that are everywhere I know this because
I am like super guilty of it all the
time I'm not mindful enough so check it
out by going to calm calm CA LM calm
/join and Julianne get 25% off a calm
premium subscription with that link and
check it out let us know how you like it
they really think you guys are gonna
enjoy it it is a very powerful app also
guys if you're running a small business
maybe you're being an entrepreneur and
congratulations if you're doing that
there's a lot of things that you need to
do in order to not get in trouble mmm
with or run your business yeah or you
know just do things right business-wise
tax wise everything like that but honey
book is really great for that sort of
thing if you need help with invoices
tracking your finances brochures all all
sorts of different things that you
wouldn't even think of when it comes to
running your own small business you're
like I make a product they buy it the
end no it's not the end there's a lot of
little things that you need to think
about a honey book is there to cover
your butt when it comes to running your
own business they help you with payment
reminders proposals invoices all the
things that are necessary to run your
own business payment is flexible also
using our code which is code Jenna
Julian you can get 50% off monthly or
annually that's $20 a month or $200 for
a whole year of organization that's 50%
off your first purchase with honey book
when you use promo code Jen and Jillian
so there's a lot of deals going on here
I think if you're a business owner a
small business owner and you need help
with this sort of thing at least check
it out I think it's really worth it
check the link in the description to get
started there and also guys the skim th
es ki mmm comm slash gin and Julian sign
your email
subscribe you're done that's all you got
to do it's completely free and then all
you get is this wonderful inbox surprise
every morning with the top news stories
and a very easy to read and understand
format it's not opinions this and that
it's not nonsense it's very very concise
easy and simple but important because
it's what's going on in the world and
the skin helps you educate yourself
every single day so you can dominate
your conversations at work about current
events and know more than other people
be better and it's free and it's
completely free also when you go to the
skim th es que IMM Tom Sloane and Julian
you're signed up to win a $250 Visa gift
card that you can buy whatever you want
with we won't tell Julian we won't just
don't tell me and then I won't tell
because then I won't know Thank You
sponsors Thank You sponsors are you
ready oh I'm ready all right I was born
in the tank it was a good commercial
break and we're back
[Music]
hi sharks
hi do you take baths yeah baths are
great aren't they they're relaxing maybe
put on a little music light a candle
oh wait music what do you have to put a
speaker in the bathroom that sounds
really annoying and then what if you
want to be on your phone then the
speaker doesn't work because it's not
close enough and it's just a nightmare
introducing bath phones their headphones
but for baths they are completely
waterproof we think and also if ah if
you know try them what what do you mean
we think we think that we don't know we
think okay keep going
there are wireless headphones for bath
use okay these are not calm down they're
not sport swimming headphones you can't
take them into the deep ocean
we've not tested that we just know that
they work in bats we've harnessed the
green tooth technology to ensure that
the water doesn't disrupt the connection
when you submerge yourself completely
and for
about everything that happened that day
because you're probably really stressed
and frustrated it is the first ever
headphones running on green tooth
unfortunately that means no devices work
with it but it works completely
underwater and maintains connection the
whole time we have been out for it but
you know it's only on blackberry do you
have a blackberry the app only works on
blackberry but no so no one bad phones
you can already get underwater
headphones just like you said that
actually work where they sell them for
swimming yes I had no idea do they use
green tooth no have you heard about
green tooth no it's great
I don't want green tooth Julian come on
no please no okay fine that was I failed
no all right it doesn't work do you want
to see the logo we developed for green
tea okay I don't have it I'll email it
to you all right cool you don't have my
email okay it's a big note from me but
thank you for your idea and your pitch
all right back in the shark hey Shay hey
sharks I'm back I'm new I can't never
been here welcome my name is Julian
mm-hmm do you have a dog yes a lot of my
inventions are from dogs yes you have a
dog do you walk your dog yeah do you do
it with a leash like a normal
well-adjusted person yes oh that's good
to know
well sometimes leashes can be really
boring it's just like it's nylon it's in
one color what's there to look at what
are you gonna be on your phone like
everyone else no you want you want to
have some stimulation and enjoyment from
the actual leash it's the after all it
is the connection that Bond's you and
your pet when you're out in the world it
is the physical umbilical cord that you
and your puppy oh my god both hold on to
throughout the walk wouldn't it be cool
if it had randomly generated information
while introducing Ricky leash it's story
that has an electron
LCD screen that's very long and thin and
small print but it randomly generates
pages and pages of Wikipedia for you to
read and educate yourself on throughout
your walk okay
honestly I'm down a thousand per thank
you
I was confused because you were yelling
know it man because you just sometimes
invent things that are just a play on
words oh no no that's not play on words
what wiki leash I don't get it okay I've
never heard of anything sure I like it
okay can't it fun it is cool so you
charge it for one whole week a minute
last year walk you have to charge it
once throughout the walk every day how
am I gonna charge it for a while you
picked me once a day that you're gonna
read wiki no you just said yes work on
the technology it's a very big battery
it's long how much is it I take
something reasonable I don't no one has
ever asked me that me having gotten this
far this also has an app for blackberry
no no nobody needs to work on iPhone and
Android okay fine
what do you think I am fine okay iPhone
app coming next fall why does it even
need an app if I'm just reading it it's
just scrolling text because the app is
literally someone at our HQ pulling up
wiki and scrolling and that's what's
showing up on your I don't want that I
want no you wanted automated automated
you want a robot doing yes please oh no
you aren't robots yes I do
all right fine the leash is $51.99 yes I
put a one at the end of it I want it to
be fifty one dollars because I just like
that number okay
comes with a charger it also needs a
monthly internet plan which is five
cents a month okay because we're doing
the equivalent of siphoning gas off of
another certain internet provider and we
get free internet so we basically just
need you to pay us so you're getting a
legal Internet yeah but there's no way
to track it to your wiki leash so the
leash only works in a place where
there's Wi-Fi no no it's cellular
yeah we got the good stuff you know
touch my leg like if it's fair enough I
will not so the benefit of having
cellular data for five cents a month is
that if you were to preload all of the
Wikipedia pages that could obviously
change at any given time I would be
reading old Wikipedia yes and I don't
want to do that I want to read new with
today's Wikipedia the most updated we
offer not a finite amount of Wikipedia
pages but an infinite it's the opposite
of finite I looked it up that's amazing
fifty one dollars and then five cents a
month is a month if you could work on
not making it charge for a week I
you got a deal what do you want three
days how much charge over the three-day
well you know only for three-day weekend
no it needs to be at least better than
the Apple watch they only get internet
on holidays Linna okay I'll work on the
technology but we have a deal how much
do you want me to invest I would love
for someone to take 51% of the business
I can't do anything I need help I don't
want responsibility how much money do
you need from me what do you think would
now inject origin books 250 bucks you
got a deal
thank you any well-read armor prototype
yet okay you know what
I take it back thank you for investing
in my company
welcome back I'm Julian Julian just
imagine I have reported in okay welcome
to welcome you sharks welcome okay
welcome thank you for welcoming me yeah
my name is Julian and I have an
invention for you okay you look like the
seventh person who has friends mm-hmm
sure do some of them suck yeah totally
so does some everyone's friends
sometimes do you always have that friend
who's asking to borrow your phone
charger or your external power bank
because they are stupid and couldn't
plan for simple days worth of phone
battery before they left their house TMT
okay yeah if I had to guess that's
probably me but yeah go on oh I need a
different jerk go okay I mean how is it
I mean how can they be so bad at
managing their phones power level and
always rely on you to save them well
time to teach them a lesson
with both me it's a Mophie that secretly
drains the battery on whatever phone is
plugged into and sends it viruses next
time your friend says can I use your
monthly you give it to them they plug it
in they say hey thinks this is really
really great it shows a fake number
going up on the top of their screen they
unplug it
viruses dead battery I'll teach them
next time they won't rely on your Mophie
to charge their phone out of the world
are you gonna it comes in sleek black
and white with a beautiful gloss finish
so your friendship ending arguments can
look really beautiful both me how much
does it cost it spelled MOF me it's a
$29 price point virus is not included
you need to pay two extra dollars for
per virus why would you need multiple
viruses well how much do you like this
person yes an awfully mean-spirited
product yeah but people are also they
deserve they earned it how much are you
looking for me to invest is it empty
check an option now 400 rubles 400
rubles I don't have rubles we can
convert it later I'm not telling you the
conversion rate to dollars you can't
just put your hand out and expect a deal
I'm not making a deal okay 500 no no
rubles fine euros no you're alive we are
in the United States we're using United
States currency not where are you
somewhere in the UK I don't know I'm
lost
how are you physically here I am a
hologram okay
I am a hologram on the set of shark tank
give me your money
no I'm a pirate wire it this is a scam
thank you for coming
you're welcome I'm out okay I think
that's it I think that's all the ones I
had today
okay I'll sudden one that's called a
cage fine it's instead of a out of the
office e-mail that you auto-reply it's
just a randomly generated vine yes I
invest in them yes okay they case fine
done deal
how much well I don't know it's an
undeveloped idea it could get you fired
I mean think about it I want vacation
vine so it's it's random that's fine so
if someone's like hey Jenna I hope
you're doing well I just want to say I
love you I hope you have a great
vacation your response could be my dick
fell off and they might no that's great
I love Knut she's funny
I can't wait ok deal vacation vacation
fine partners thank you alright vacation
we connect ok I could that is quite
literally something I could actually
invent I could probably figure out how
to do that be a vine please I could prop
like all it would take is for me to look
up or write out the words on a computer
to each find mm-hmm have them go through
a random generator ok and have some sort
of auto email response engine it needs
to be embedded in the email and it needs
to loop and at the top it says I'll BRB
here's the vine in the meantime fair
enough vacation fun actually someone one
of you guys who watches this podcaster
listens to it is way way way smarter
than me I can probably do it faster but
yeah that's it that's an actually doable
invention fake age fund I'm down well
thank you for coming in to Shark Tank
number two hopefully I did you some
justice and did good yeah you did good
those of everyone work their bark and
arrow is quite something offensive is it
something else as well
well pretty good doing honestly I you
know last I will say last time I you
know when we were doing the first
episode of shark tank on this podcast I
had some of those ideas brewing yeah you
did I had them a Bruin for like weeks
and I was developing this one I did
today so if they're bad it's okay
they were good I liked them you always
have good ideas well thank you I really
like the authentic style pet restaurant
where only pet skinny dogs are you can
go take your dog to eat like you're
taking your dog out to dinner yeah it's
funny it is funny and you can put a
little like bib on them yeah sit at the
table and a dog comes up and says would
you like any appetizers no the dog comes
out with their food and eats it in front
of people
the dogs sitting at the table and then
growls and tells something yeah you see
a lot of dark rites happening it's very
complicated yeah Wow it was good though
Julian I really liked it good inventions
I'm glad good Shark Tank thank you for
welcome it's like a real episode of
shark tank they don't they don't make
deals for everything no in fact they go
through whole episodes and not invest in
[ __ ]
it's Jerry Robert oh my god all right
John thoughts of my boy and Mark cutemon
who doesn't eat gluten and then
sometimes he does when he wants
julienned oh thank you guys for watching
and listening to the podcast we
appreciate you guys let us know in the
comments any ideas that you might have
for us for future podcast you guys have
been really killing over the idea is
actually like a lot of really fun ideas
we did a lot of quizzes recently so we
might cool it on the quizzes so but yeah
let us know thank you again for
listening be good we'll be live on
Twitch and we'll see you next week bye
[Music]